As with every James Gunn movie, observant fans
will notice plenty of extra goodies and Easter
eggs hiding in plain sight, and his latest
superhero adventure is no exception. Here
are several of the more subtle references and
Easter eggs that you missed in The Suicide Squad.
Moments before the battle on Jotunheim, Task Force
X briefs the Thinker on the myriad ways he needs
to behave himself, lest they dispatch him with
extreme prejudice. During this rooftop scene,
Harley Quinn repeatedly interjects with
jokey cautions about things like covering
his mouth whenever he coughs. The Easter egg,
however, is buried in one of these lines:
"If we find out you have personalized
license plates, you die."
Vanity plates can often be annoying, so
the line gets a laugh whether you read
something deeper into it or not. But
Harley's hatred of vehicle signage is
actually a reference to her ex-boyfriend,
none other than the Joker. It's also one of
the only times in The Suicide Squad where they
acknowledge the existence of the earlier film.
In the previous outing for the titular team,
the Joker was infamously played by Jared Leto.
Much like everything else with the first movie,
the initial response to his look was
massive, promising internet buzz,
but the final product has subsequently been
deemed a disappointment.
Symbolic of theLeto Joker's on-the-nose tendencies that
made him hard to swallow was his vehicle,
an adapted Infiniti G35 dubbed "The Vaydor."
That vehicle also featured vanity plates that
read "HAHAHA." Harley has since moved on in
the relationship department, but clearly,
she still has some things that annoy
her when it comes to her ex-puddin'.
When the team assembles in a charming local
Corto Maltese watering hole for a few drinks,
the club contains several notable faces. One of
the dancers is none other than Pom Klementieff,
the distinctive-looking Canadian-born French actor
and model who played Mantis in 2017's Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol. 2 as well as Avengers: Infinity
War and Avengers: Endgame. She doesn't have any
lines this time around, but sharp-eyed James
Gunn fans know that he has a tight, fun-loving
group of friends and collaborators. It's fun
to see her offering support for the filmmaker.
You can also spot the legendary Lloyd Kaufman.
He’s the mastermind behind the Troma Entertainment
indie film factory. And he has given rise
to multiple film talents including Gunn,
who in 1995 got his start writing Tromeo and
Juliet. It was at Troma that Gunn learned how
to write and produce films, scout locations,
work with actors, and make and distribute ads for the finished product.
Gunn also worked on such
other Troma productions as 1999's Terror Firmer.
Kaufman can be spotted on the dance floor,
clinging to a young woman while dancing alongside
Peacemaker. To be a fly on the wall for whatever
conversation took place between those two!
Gunn also pays tribute to his
former mentor Kaufman with a
blink-and-you'll-miss-it clip from Troma's
most famous film, the 1984 cult classic The
Toxic Avenger. Next time you watch The
Suicide Squad, see if you can spot it.
A pair of end credits scenes bring
back two members of the Suicide Squad.
These two characters could not be any
more different, never met in the film,
and would seem to have very different
futures in the DC Extended Universe.
First, we see the bizarre, bug-eyed Weasel
resurrected. Played on set by James' brother
Sean Gunn, who also provided reference points
for Rocket Raccoon in the Guardians of the Galaxy
films, the character first appeared in the pages
of DC Comics via 1985's The Fury of Firestorm #36.
Believe it or not, the John Monroe version
of Weasel was a Stanford University student,
and then a teacher at Vandemeer University. Much
like Polka-Dot Man, his presence in comics over
the years has generally been as a punchline,
both on the page, and for fans in real life.
In those early comics, he was a serial killer
whose appearance came from a sharp-clawed costume.
In the comics, he slashed the throat of the
Thinker, causing Rick Flag to kill him.
As faras the movie is concerned, Weasel is seen coughing
up water and surviving the carnage on the beach.
He scampers away, perhaps headed into town to grab
a drink with Lloyd Kaufman and Pom Klementieff.
In the second end credits scene, we see a pair
of Waller's newly emboldened minions rushing to
the hospital, shocked that someone survived the
battle of Jotunheim. You can be forgiven if you
have your fingers crossed for Polka-Dot Man, but
alas, lying in that hospital bed is Peacemaker.
This revelation almost certainly foreshadows the
character's resurrection in a Gunn-engineered HBO
Max Peacemaker series, one the filmmaker recently
announced he had completed 8 episodes of filming
alongside Cena. Peacemaker is currently slated to
debut on the streaming service in January 2022.
Talk about a line that gets maximum
impact with minimum dialogue.
WhenAmanda Waller introduces Robert DuBois by saying:
"He's in prison for putting Superman
in the UCU with a kryptonite bullet."
You immediately know he is not a man to be
trifled with. Alas, there is no Superman
cameo in The Suicide Squad, but there is a
precedent to the whole kryptonite bullet idea.
Ask anyone who knows anything about the man from
Krypton, and they can tell you the one way to
kill Superman: Kryptonite. The fictional material
first appeared in the radio serial The Adventures
of Superman in June of 1943, followed by its first
comic book appearance in November 1949's Superman#61.
The material originates from the hero's
home planet, is generally harmless to humans,
but could potentially prove lethal for the Man of
Steel. Both Batman and Lex Luthor are generally
known to keep some close, just in case.
The character of Bloodsport dates back
to 1987's Superman vol. 2 #4 and has since
become a longtime adversary of Superman.
Initially depicted in that post-Rambo time period
as a Vietnam veteran, he was brought into the
fold by Luthor, who recruited him to assassinate
Superman after equipping him with a Punisher-like
stash of weapons that included a gun that fired
needles filled with kryptonite. This Bloodsport
was angry at the citizens of Metropolis,
saying they took for granted the freedoms
he and his brother had fought hard to preserve.
After Bloodsport slaughtered dozens of people,
Superman intervened, taking a Kryptonite bullet
in the process, and requiring medical attention.
Take a close look at the poster for The Suicide
Squad, and you'll notice several Easter eggs.
One is the raining starfish,
an obvious reference to Starro.
It's the big bad, mind-controlling monster
Task Force X battles at the end of the film.
Another seems to be referring to the beloved
DC Comics miniseries that introduced the
modern Suicide Squad and contained
some of their earliest misadventures.
First spotted by the site Comics Beat,
the reference can be found masquerading
as a palm tree frond just under the
word "The" in the poster tagline:
"They're dying to save the world." Look super
close, and you'll see it: The word "Legends."
Most likely, this Easter egg refers to the
warmly remembered, six-issue Legends comic
series DC released in 1986 and 1987. The comics
featured new takes on the Flash, Justice League,
and Captain Marvel, but perhaps most
significantly introduced the modern
incarnation of the Suicide Squad in issue #3.
The series had DC heroes battling Darkseid,
and the third issue had Amanda Waller organizing
a Black Ops team to take on Glorious Godfrey,
one of Darkseid's elite and a New God
of Apokolips. She selected Rick Flag,
Bronze Tiger, Deadshot, Enchantress, and Captain
Boomerang for the mission. Many of whom are also
featured in Gunn and David Ayer’s films.
Comics fans love to see a tip of the cap
to those who came before, and this minor
acknowledgment of John Ostrander, Len Wein,
John Byrne, Karl Kesel, and others who helped
build the modern Suicide Squad is a nice touch.
Gunn is undoubtedly one of the most
comic book-savvy super fans working
in Hollywood today, and this seems to be an
acknowledgment that the publishing of Legends,
which would have come out when he was 20
years old, was a formative experience.
His demise might just get the
biggest laugh in The Suicide Squad,
an impressive feat in a movie filled with
punchlines as potent as Bloodsport's weaponry.
Emerging quietly in the background of
the story, a seemingly insignificant
van-driving character goes from chauffeur
to tag-along to full-fledged martyr,
inspiring the Squad to take down Jotunheim and
ultimately rebel against Waller and her program.
His name is Milton, and he first gained the
attention of many sharp-eyed moviegoers when
he could be glimpsed in the background of the
rooftop scene, strutting around like he was
another super-powered member of the Suicide Squad.
When a fan posted a screengrab and asked "Who isthis dude?????"
the Twitter-savvy filmmaker
simply replied: "Oh, that? That's Milton."
Comic fans immediately leapt into action,
speculating that he could be the sideshow
character Milton Fine, also known as the Amazing
Brainiac. Or perhaps he’s a gender-swapped version
of the female Amazon warrior Hippolyta
Milton. If true, that could lead to a
connection with Wonder Woman, which could mean
a Justice League and Suicide Squad crossover!
Nope, it’s just Milton. The stone-faced, ill-fated
driver is played by Julio Ruiz, an actor who
has appeared on Vice Principals, Preacher, and
S.W.A.T. If you want to see something adorable,
track down a March 2021 article from Ruiz's
hometown newspaper, the Laredo Morning Times.
It proudly hypes up the fact that he's
appearing alongside Margot Robbie, Idris Elba,
and other Hollywood stars in a summer tentpole
superhero film, but clearly has no idea why.
Milton's barely acknowledged death triggers
Harley Quinn, as does the acknowledgment from
the others that they hardly realized he wasn't
waiting in the van. Like the death of Javelin,
it emboldens her to turn tragedy into
triumph and avenge her fallen comrades.
Are there any grander implications
to this storyline in the DCEU?
Can we look forward to a Batman/Milton team-up
movie in the near future? Probably not,
but you can follow Julio Ruiz on social media
for more information on the mysterious Milton,
and where his story goes from here.
Check out one of our newest videosright here! Plus, even more Looper videos
about The Suicide Squad are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.